I'm about to enter the West Bank
and as you can see from this sign
Israelis are not allowed to enter.
This is a Palestinian zone.
My Israeli crew that's been with me for a few days
must remain behind
and I'm gonna switch over to an all Palestinian crew.
So it's like this court ordered custody fight
where I'm leaving one divorced parent
to go stay with another divorced parent
and both parents don't really like me.
Oh, I wanna buy it.
Oh, that's so nice of you, thank you.
That's nice, he just gave this to me,
that's very nice.
I'll be back in five minutes to take more for free.
(audience laughs)
What is your name?
My name is Sami.
Sami, Sami, okay, alright.
Sami, where are you from?
You live-
Yes, I'm from Bethlehem.
Oh, from Bethlehem.
Yes, I live here, I work here, I'm born here,
I married here also.
Wow.
Yes.
What do you have here?
I have some coffee
and I have also very delicious tea.
This coffee looks very, very strong.
Yes, very strong as you
King of the jungle.
No, you got me mixed up with someone else.
I'm Conan, meek and mild.
This was all sugar.
Oh my god, oh that is very strong.
No wonder you are so hah.
You drink a lot of this?
Yes.
Yes, yes, you seem a little crazy.
(laughs)
You're crazy in the head.
This is for you, I put this right in here, okay?
You are very kind.
I am very kind but you were very nice.
Oh, do I kiss you too, okay.
You are very heavy-
But not the lips, right?
Well, if you want, come.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheering)
My heart is like my face.
(laughs)
Thank you.
What's good dancing music, for dancing?
He's good?
This man show me how to dance,
how do I dance?
I got it.
This is it, look at this now.
Do you like this?
(audience laughs)
He's gone, where did he go?
He stopped, I guess I win.
I want to buy something,
I haggle with you.
How much for this?
700 shekels-
Yes.
is bullshit,
I give you 200 shekels.
I saw one just down the street
that looks just like this.
450 shekels is bullshit.
(laughs)
I give you 500 shekels.
I give you 390 shekels.
Okay.
Yes?
Yes.
Yeah, I did it.
I haggled.
(audience cheering)
Carrots?
Okay, how much?
Yeah, one.
I just bought this
but I don't have what goes in.
What goes in here?
What is this?
You know what, I'm gonna do watermelon and mint.
I like that.
This is like watching my dad do the Christmas lights
back in the 70s, except you're not swearing
and kicking things.
Okay, what this gentleman is telling me is
that this hookah is no good.
It's decorative, it doesn't work.
It's not meant to work.
This is bad, the whole thing no good.
My fault, right?
I bought a decorative hookah.
Learn from my mistake.
Next time you're in the West Bank,
look out for this guy.
I like this guy
but he doesn't make it clear
that he's selling you a decorative hookah
and not a functioning hookah.
Alright, alright, alright.
Go for it, Sami.
That is some fine watermelon and mint.
Okay, he's high on watermelon.